[la musique]
la communauté demande depuis longtemps
agi mais nous n'avions pas comment
sexuelle précisément l'Internet comme on dit
visiter parce que nous ne l'avons pas
jamais besoin maintenant juste
tout le monde a jeté cette histoire d'Amérique où
les gars l'ont fait, nous avons décidé que pourquoi
voudrais et non
parce que la vérité est que les gens sont réels dans
d'autres villes comme ils le veulent vraiment
regarde ces animaux
bien qu'il ne soit pas possible de venir à Moscou et
nous y avons pensé maintenant
s'en approcher car c'est
où nous n'avons pas encore ouvert
c'est pourquoi sous certains
le rendement de la garde était donc
y travailler penser et emménager
cette direction
[la musique]
bien comment voir qu'ils sont géniaux du tout
à cette trouvaille ils réagissent
assez de contentement est sorti qu'ils avaient l'habitude de
aux gens ils grimpent constamment dans le cadre
nous dépendons à nouveau de l'animal car
que nous en avons un gros, bien sûr, eh bien, c'est le premier
ils sont tous différents, par exemple, ces
derrière moi et les filles et elles sont juste quelque chose
weed et en général ils ne dépendent pas de moi ici
donc chacun a sa propre approche
une sorte d'intérêt, c'est-à-dire ces
léger brouhaha derrière est mais dans ce quelque chose
et il y a une fonctionnalité parce qu'elle est vivante
être ne peut pas tout comme un
[la musique]